sourire incapable d'arrêter un an un cap
à we have band ce qu'on va cliquer ce
que je peux arrêter dans un enjeu
l'opposition qu'est ce que c'est pas du
tout on est inscrit aux
personnes pensent que je vais arrêter
dans ce que vous pouvez
arrêter mais voilà alors à vie alors je
vais vous dire quelque chose quand je
fus maurer a arrêtés va
il est revenu chez mercedes alors qu'ils
avaient aucune chance de gagner en fait
sa femme a dit quand il est arrêté
pendant un an et cinq fois par jour et
sauter en parachute tellement ils
avaient besoin d'adrénaline tellement
des besoins et vous c'est pareil cerise
sur un live arcade est en vacances au
bout de deux semaines était vous fait-il
mais m il a été patron de shell s'est
pas
trompé il est déjà patron de chaîne oui
on n'est pas contre chelsea capeletto
dépôt de bilan mais les
patrons du groupe ares dont j'ai bien
compris fr patron de chaîne on a été
très bon un très bon par contre pas voir
je pense que vous pouvez arrêter un an
parce que vous avez plein d'activités
annexes quoi là-bas plainte bertal vie
bien évidemment évidemment c'est sûr et
certain même voulu faire du paddle c'est
vrai qu'ils sont pas des moteurs mais
rentrer dans les rentrées dans les 300
way qualité dvd moi je vous verrai bien
le précurseur du paddle mondiale chef de
quelque chose dans le padd louette
travaux sinon
[Rires]
je fais beaucoup chauffer la tête avec
le sait chauffer ma tête je dis
merci
complément me va droit au coeur serré
remercie alors le coeur c'est oui bah
c'est là vous prenez mon coeur ne sais
pas
tubert d'être vous ne pourriez pas parce
que deux millions de gens serait
orphelin de vous chaque soir
[Applaudissements]
vous savez gilles 5000 personnes étaient
bien orphelin de vous sur scène
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai ouï à moi je pense je peux
pas je veux pas je me dis en télé je
vous dire qu'il n'ya jamais personne qui
est sorti dans la rue pour réclamer un
animateur ah non je vous lis on vous
laisse pas arrêter tous les mecs sans
quoi les way je vais arrêter ce avec la
folie les gens s'en foutent totalement
allant mais je vous le dis j'en ai vu
pour les sons il a arrêté pour exciter
la folie excuse moi thierry j'aime
beaucoup mais bon ça dure et sans foot
et non mais c'est vrai tout le monde
s'en fout les mecs tout le monde te
rends tu arrêtes ton monde s'en fout tu
crois qu'il ya des gens qui vont
certainement leur galère encore fini
c'est fini je le répète ça et mes soeurs
à questions pour un champion ça
recommence a maintenu mais non mais non
mais ferme et douce enfin nous étonnons
surcoût code and judy
daniel non moi je crois que vous ne
m'arrêterai pas c'est une drogue ou
alors peut-être moi je voudrais bien
refaire de la scène
de la laiterie 0 pas de calais c'est le
meilleur jeu
c'est tellement drôle moi moi je pense
que vous il ya des chances que vous
pouvez arrêter j'en suis je pense parce
que j'essaye de comprendre je vous ai
signé cinq ans la fois d'avant ouais et
là on lie deux ans cette voilà huit ans
voilà et ça devait être signés notamment
innovant mais ça devait être si mal à la
10ème cette voie là et fin janvier
devait un truc qui devra être signée
normalement vous avez pas scier fin
janvier début février un mars fait comme
emmanuel macron après centres après pour
des guides
pour vous payer donc sam électrique voit
ça c'est là mon avis c'est franck happi
tour en capitaux mais à mon avis un truc
alors vous non pour moi vous êtes jeunes
vous êtes en forme et vous pouvez tout
une patate
me faire des êtres producteurs vous
intéressez à la crypto monnaie faire du
paddle vous pouvez tout faire sur des
bateaux aujourd'hui si vous arrêtez vous
savez très bien que quand on revient un
an après bruce a tenté impression et
c'est fini c'est fini ça veut dire que
ce serait la mort sont si on arrête
c'est fini à la wii bien s'arrêter un an
survenu
dans un train bah oui c'est la
locomotive s'arrêtent les bas-fonds des
cabanons non mais c'est vrai
pour moi craon compte pas le nombre de
ballons c'est pas la légende oui vous
détient la boîte sur 12 mois on s'en fou
c'était la voiture nous
faire entrer dans la police
il fait rentrer partout il a encore
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
essayé
d'effacer sa cible a essayé n'ai jamais
réussi
à
continuer moi pour ça vous allez pas
vous arrêter parce que vous savez très
bien que si pendant un an vous
disparaissez des radars c'est fini et ça
c'est insupportable mais finalement 8e
disparaît d'amour s&p l'antenne
c'est la personne
avec quelqu'un de faible quand même ça
veut dire que vous pensez qu'il n'a pas
le mental l'adrénaline dessous de
1500 mètres carrés
3000 mètres carrés
tout doute eh bien regardez il se passe
un truc sur internet il peut se lancer
dans la salle de la fois qu'il est bien
des ils sont fous du business
aso et peu créatif la chamba jamais vous
bordel avec celui recettes je sais pas
qui vous êtes réellement la radio des
choses
du même chose a créé en mai les oui je
fais de la radio show with you oui je
vais faire de la radio est aujourd'hui
rend t d mais on ne sait pas faire en
sièges
aux sirènes oui c'est vous voulez je
vous fais tout votre business plan
d'autonomie chamberland
voilà les téléspecteurs gêner ses
bagages il va perdre beaucoup donné
est ce que vous pouvez faire moi je vous
conseille de vous lancer vous faites un
une tournée de paddle mondiale dire que
ça nous implanter dans tous les pays du
monde et
ensuite c'est déjà faux et vous céder
des terrains de ouf henriette des
piscines autres femmes ont un vent de
plein de trucs à vous inventez est ce
que vous pouvez faire ensuite on joue
c'est au niveau des n a cessé de prendre
des terres de paddle de mf
c'est lui moi excusez moi elle vous veut
du mal
[Rires]
qui mettra un don sur votre on vend déjà
des tables on enlève tes tous les
footballeurs en achète on voit déjà des
maisons n'ont pas énormément
choper parlez-lui nous vendait des
joueurs et un jeu
vidéo paddle qui n'existe pas encore la
science s'est passé rien
alors allez-y parce que vous savez ce
qu'on dit toujours on gagne toujours une
guerre à la maison vietnam états unis
pourquoi les etats-unis ont perdu parce
que rod et se battre au vietnam ici vous
êtes chez vous c'est votre vietnam un
beau challenge serait peut-être d'aller
sur une autre chaîne où là il sera un
challenge parce qu'il si vous êtes chez
vous faites deux millions et tout ça
c'est votre chaîne quelle que soit
l'heure elle est sur une autre chaîne
alors je vous dis que je dirais que j'ai
regardé sur une autre chaîne c'est fini
jamais jamais jamais c'est que j'arrête
away ou je continue ici je n'irai jamais
sur une tête hors intérêts ce modèle
s'appelle la loyauté mathieu
lippé tué
sa famille on la quitte pas voilà même
je m'entends très bien avec d'autres
chaînes mais c'est vrai mais c'est vrai
une liberté te dirai jamais voilà
non